oh no I never want to be taking hard
trees okay we have an awesome episode of
hot boxing today I'm Mike Tyson other
than Britain and I guess here tonight
there's no other than the most glamorous
man of the piece Metta World Peace my
name is my name ed wish I'd known me I
had a rough professional career right
and we don't fast and I'm not gonna sit
here and lie to you and tell you I'm not
gonna smoke with Mike Tyson
I don't I don't like to smoke on
television I don't think I don't believe
you should be out there drinking I've
done it but I don't believe in it but I
think CBD is great right right you see
BD yeah and I definitely smoke I'm not
in sports they say sorry sorry my big
bro so it's forts they say they say um
don't smoke but we grew up smoking right
yeah and we tell them so he's saying we
don't smoke but with some everybody
smoke here you don't say everybody
smoked and you know yeah I agree I just
embrace it man it's a powerful medicine
for us athletes yeah it is man you know
I'm just like I'm just like you know uh
it's good medicine yeah it's great
medicine it's better than alcohol I
believe I don't mean it'll take the
business away from the alcohol companies
but it's better yeah you know because
alcohol it eats away at you makes you
slow brings down your joints right and
he's just
you got mentally and good medicine yeah
I'm into the CBD companies marijuana
companies I think is booming now and
they trying to find ways to make it more
legal you know and everybody's trying to
figure it out which is good yeah so with
all that being said on the smoker Mike
this is what it is man listen this is
the future yeah Khun Danai the future of
marijuana cannabis amusing selling
purchasing and I think acting yeah yeah
and I think you know in sports it's not
as accepting and I think it has this
time in place I think it does have this
time in place and you know not like you
can't go onto the court and smoke when
you get home maybe you'll have us have a
joint you get five joints a year smoke
yeah we notice you can smoke at least
five times a year right like Christmas
yeah yeah right that's a good holiday
and then like you but if you smoke on a
you know more than five sounds a year be
finally 200 grand
Wow yeah let's see no it's not the NBA
pie I'm just killing time and I believe
in like don't hide it from what you do
don't hide things you do you know like
evenly you see the gay communities
coming out he seemed able to be free and
fly yeah you know and and you you try to
promote good things positive education
all stuff yeah I smoking John Mehta
you're being you're a big mental health
advocate I am that's about the head tell
us about that yeah Mike let's tell these
guys from everybody babe I got problems
man
Oh
only if you knew you saying the right
chip only if you know oh yeah I know man
you don't just say like I was a wild boy
our boys come and I just have just was
always mad I don't know why and grew up
actually watching Tyson we doing well
farewell fool could we gamble with the
fools yeah yeah we got the percent I'm a
mother who's that go down there and I
give them the food stand by to see where
my money's not allowed to buy food but
they let you do it hey but you know but
they put thing I owe you to get what
about what about the white peanut butter
the government's taking the white bread
bread the bigger change that you the
blogger freezes it turns into a knife
you can actually cut somebody with this
cheese I put the cheese out all night
one night all right and we gonna
barbecue sauce I put the cheese on the
grill you know we gonna eat a
cheeseburger
the cheese was sweated was it melting
the cheese was it was sweating it was it
melted song like I cannot be putting us
into my body
Wow you know and everybody know the
cheese that if you have you got hard
over four days and a turn tonight you
can I could carve socially I love being
on this show just like you know we're so
poor you know it's poor and I can
remember waiting for the mailman to get
the check for the welfare check waiting
for them to come and get my mother
welfare typical mail instill a check
yeah yeah yeah you know I think I don't
know but you know what you know it's
things that you can do to make you feel
comfortable that's safe you know I think
it's less accidents with people who
smoke yeah and people who drink
you're more mindful huh you're more
mindful yeah say some stuff is too much
me now me personally I rather CBD dear I
prefer like they have they have CBD
everything now yeah I like to see
because you know
yeah so they gave me that option for CBD
amazing what marijuana community to all
there was it called culture yeah amazing
what they're doing
yeah yeah for sure deafness tree yeah no
question and you never took the tote
before have you the what EMT the a
retired EMT what's that five immuno do
find video DMT what is that um that's a
very honest I'm like a venom from this
frog in Sahara Desert Wow busted
Buster's pimples on hey get something
merry then you scrape it off and put it
in the pipe and smoke are you carrying
me yeah and then it really it takes you
to the yeah I've never done anything for
marijuana oh yeah you know obviously
it's obviously you can get anything year
one in the world anything you want yeah
I already wanted that's it the only one
smoked marijuana
and I'm fine with that yeah you know and
I smoke sometimes and yeah but I see
people do all the things which some of
us are like yeah you might not want to
be doing that cuz it's not a good look
for you some our friends don't crazy
that crackhead just like you gotta get
off it you gotta get off [ __ ] that man
you know like you know come on like it's
certain things that you should not be
doing yeah I believe and CBD is not one
of them cocaine crack cocaine and [ __ ]
your dick up you can't [ __ ] wit [ __ ] oh
man anything that turns your dick soft
is bad don't want to do you know are in
the other cheek you know yeah I think um
[ __ ] that it's true that you know this
is hold any Wesson is a really
transformative medicine they say so you
yeah they always hit they also say when
you drink you don't you don't get a deep
sleep
yeah that's right so you got a pick and
choose down some people some people
abuse
drinking alcohol oh [ __ ] oh damn a
beautiful [ __ ] alcohol just destroys
your body man no you changing your name
is such a powerful thing can you talk a
little bit about that and how you chose
Metta World Peace yeah yeah definitely
man you know I was
becoming inspired learning how to
breathe learn how to meditate the thing
that I had told I didn't have when I was
growing up is good so therapy counseling
you know you get all different types of
counseling some some people want to give
you medicine so you go to a psychiatrist
or you can go to a psychologist which is
like not really medicines more passion
emotion and stuff I'm talking you know
it so when you diagnose people the right
way you can pick or choose what you need
according you know to what you have so
sometimes people are misdiagnosed you
know so they need to offer the the
psychology is very important did the
mental health therapy are the other
options are very important because
sometimes people just need someone to
talk to or need to learn how to
parenting it's simple things like learn
how to be a parent oh man like it's just
amazing being here with you because I
watch you and when you took your first
loss yeah we cried I told you the story
of me and my dad cry well everybody was
crying in the house my mom was crying oh
god right so everybody was crying we
know Queensbridge in the hood we all
crying right into my dad says everyone's
on punishment I'm crying gotta go to bed
you know if I want to hear what Mike is
saying like we had to leave we can't
even hear you say it was a bad nothing
put us to bed and but I'm a big fan of
the whole process of boxing you know so
anyway I forgot the Millers question I
just wanted to say that I had to get it
out tell my kids you know I can't
believe the me my wife our first year we
almost killed each other married wow I
can't believe that we're in the state of
a relationship and respect that we have
my it's [ __ ] baffles me yeah so very
sheer it was murder
I mean yeah I mean murder I've been in
my own my wife now for six years so 107
years and um you know you just learn oh
yes you know how to pick your battles
yeah but yeah it's great you know the
kids is great the ball playing sports my
son's going to Princeton or afraid or
st. John's
thank you that's amazing I'm excited
that's so awesome yeah and you were
saying it's for computer science oh yeah
man so my son she's got some Brainiac
yeah he's really good
you too man mathematician that was my
major but it was too hard to do and play
basketball sorry I dropped in with an
MBA but that was I did pick math as a
major I wanted to get architecture did
you have fun an MBA I have amazing time
yeah amazing time you know
championship defensive player yeah I
have rough times but I have amazing
times like I got one all-star one one
defensive player here oh yeah one
championship it's also three defense
played he is one MBA all 13 you know you
know and they're just like I be happy
pretty that's pretty good like it's not
what I want it I wanted more all-stars
and then the year I got suspended I
really believed I would've gotten VP
that year and that hurt me because I
have as well players like you know when
you get the championship it's a certain
thing certain things that mean something
you know as a when you're athlete and
MVP is one of them you know MVPs one
right and I was right there the year
before that I finished six in MVP voting
and I got defensive player of the year
averaging 18 points in the next year so
I was averaging 24 points right before
the bra happen you know sock that was my
year
if that was my year we just on fire more
and people yeah I was definitely angry
PETA yeah can I ask you two questions
about that
yeah so you know that you had the malice
and the palace yeah the legendary at all
yeah after that season um you wanted to
get out of Indiana oh man
oh so much was tough and a lot of people
there I thought did you make you to
Indiana God it wasn't man yo man I'm
just curious like you know what you were
going through that you felt like you had
to get out of there it wasn't Indiana it
was happening to Chicago also when I was
when I was there I was I was
a miserable kid because although I took
everything personal to person I know how
to let me just let slide so when I when
I when I first cheated all my wife it
really messed me up coming I wanted I
had this vision of um being with one
person forever really
yeah leave that [ __ ] yeah believe it I
believe it I believe it a marriage
absolutely just like you have your
family and that's it that's all that
matters that's it that's all that
matters but when you're young that's not
all that mess right yeah I'm saying I
made tons of mistakes and um you know
it's tough like experiences like that
it's very humbling because when you're
not doing things the right way it's not
good
can't do things try do things together
right way and but you keep it but just
know you're not gonna be perfect
so comes to grips with things and you
change your name to Metta World Peace I
have to fight but right before the fight
my grandma passed away grandma my
grandma passed away everything was that
she brought everybody together it was
you know and when she passed away I
heard a lot that month I was really
stressed sleeping and just passed me
around right before that so that coulda
had something to do with how I was
feeling that could add something to do
what I was feeling you know during a
brawl and then Ben Wallace he he's
somebody yeah so he passed away I think
the day before that brought somebody he
he was on air I think somebody close to
his family that's the story I've heard
he was on he was on edge also yeah yeah
he was on edge also he was feeling a
certain way a great player yeah you guys
were both like super fiery young players
you know the I was a big [ __ ]
Ben Ben was very strong yeah very
athletic
he was four-time Defensive Player of the
Year you know and I take that personally
because like you know I'm saying yeah
it's only at that era is only two people
who can talk about defensive play in a
year it was me and Ben hmm and he got it
four times and I was suspended one of
them years you know oh yeah I led the
league in flagrant fouls so I'm just
like not getting you know I'm losing all
the accolade opportunities you know that
materials and materialistic things not
everything I can ring is out everything
is not your life but if you have the
opportunities
VP now work for it it is your life it
worked for ya what's what I've dreamed
about since I was a kid when in these
yeah what I know I know so it was cool
to have those opportunities you know and
like smoking with people you just wanted
to smoke with a long time and I'm
getting into sports yeah it's so cool
but someone just sewed the Tyson ranch
yeah like this is amazing yeah yeah the
man stated art transcending man resort
for cannabis the Tyson ranch is really
an amazing place because you shoulda
came to the festival with the Caravelle
really it was awesome you put it up
there let me pull it out to see ya man
and I love the podcast said I just said
up my package it looks we got one camera
two lights and I came here and it's like
where's your park at my house yeah yeah
we love to come over there pull it up
he's happy you don't have to depend on
anyone else
yeah yeah right
right it's really it's really cool
innermost hardships 7,000 kids screaming
Mike's name Tyson Tyson this is it right
here is that where was this at this was
out in Desert Hot Springs is where the
ranch is gonna be is gonna be a whole
cannabis resort Wow lazy rubber runway
full who's dope is fun look at Mike
really cool you know Mike's looking like
an action hero out there if chai with
the people man thought about the people
yeah it was awesome
be kind wow that's what it's all about
now that's what this whole thing is
about you know yeah yeah yeah so we've
got cannabis products yeah teeth got
flour really great flour
CBD products okay we'll hook you up with
a little goodie bag so uh yeah don't
smoke a lot I do like to smoke CBD
because I believe you know and see we do
you know you had Larry Sanders who quit
the NBA because he couldn't smoke you
know and well if they thirty years so it
is K it is cuz he left a lot of money on
the table I'm like this guy like just
don't smoke and every 100 is not it's
not like that it's not worth like and he
felt that way and he's a and he's a very
good kid he's doing arts and stuff
Ritchie loves music yeah and he's very
you want do movies he he's a good kid
good kid and he loves the smoke you
should have when you show talk about
story Larry Sanders yeah oh yeah really
amazing story sounds like Ricky Williams
a little bit it a little bit different
though yeah cuz you know sometimes Rick
and I love Rick Ricky Ricky has similar
past like Ricky was doing things wrong
same time play around the same time and
wasn't really focused on football hey
maybe he was going through his own
things but I don't know the story I'm
assuming he was going to his own things
but he was an amazing football player
yeah alright yeah um you know so Larry
was different
all defensive team was gonna get
defensive player of the year was gonna
be Dennis Rodman type defender he was an
amazing defender yeah but you know upset
to see he didn't play it's a great time
on a new level yeah yeah
I now start my only so people gotta look
for X verse exports calm okay
it definitely we're going live in like
six weeks but we're gonna be doing
sports but it also definitely check us
out if you can yeah X versus X sports
yeah x vs x sports knockout awesome what
else you doing these days man I'm doing
a lot coaching you know I'm coaching so
like I coach our coach kids basketball
you know you know I love it that's great
coach men also I like coaching men
because coaching men is real cool it's a
lot of adult leagues like I played at
Equinox plant Equinox I'm in the league
I play at Beverly Hills High School
Leeds I played I played in basketball
league I mean I always played in
basketball leagues and is levels for
everyone yeah yeah it's fine
that's awesome you know your people
stoked while you're out there sometimes
but not sometimes good crowd sometimes
it's not we play against ABA teams okay
you know I want to just I just want to
coach Baskin man and I love cheese and
kids how to play you know the game of
basketball and and adults I love the
adults I got two back-to-back
Championships where Coast arenal Jackson
at Palisades high school I coached the
girls while I was in the NBA and I was
doing the defense shell defense and
moving right away and make moves you
know I'm a coach and I love it and like
did you know it's saying what you doing
things you love yeah exactly
born in New York City okay
lived in Brooklyn so I was 11
my brother and I out here I came out of
trouble 'we had a hot childhood dream to
play in the NFL
oh nice and I'ma give you up in New York
you be a hothead I know dude the ball is
in Ch it wouldn't exist it's true dude I
don't know if I would have played
football living growing up in Brooklyn
[ __ ] but you know came to football my
freshman year high school went to
University of Arizona had a good career
got drafted in the second round 39th
overall by the Jags in 2009 and then
played six years in the league came out
of that you know had laundry list of
injuries concussions surgeries all that
[ __ ] cannabis was really my preferred
source of pain management when I came
out of the league started talking about
that started writing about that and you
know the next thing I know I'm a
cannabis advocate um you know right I
formed in order to about it what do you
think about cannabis and how it's like
people still saying don't do it a lot of
people a lot of people yeah I mean
there's you know the federal government
has a patent on cannabinoids as
neuroprotection suckle an antioxidant so
they know that it can actually help the
brain heal oh it's beautiful
so you know for me with concussions
being such a big issue in the NFL and
mental health issues with ball players
yeah you know cannabis to me is the
should be the number one remedy for that
yeah I think um I think so I think I
haven't done a lot of research but I
think so yeah I mean I like to use the
lotion when I first started using the
CBD lotion yeah it's great and all good
yeah makes you feel good man and it's
better you know as warriors were [ __ ]
maniacs
you know we're programmed for an
adrenaline rush you know and to fuel
that and so when we come out of the
sport what are we gonna do we're gonna
go party we're gonna go drink we're
gonna go take pills we're gonna do yeah
I don't I don't really know I never get
any much smoke weed that's great for you
so you guys didn't like that something
uh yeah dude just about bad that's the
good you tell me I don't want to I'll
tell you what I've done it out say I
smoked weed you know yeah that's it
cocaine Wow membrane Wow Wow cocaine in
the membrane Wow acid that suicide oh
you know I want these how and expanders
them but I wouldn't encourage kids
absolutely no absolutely madam like okay
you know well just don't kill yourself
you know like be responsible you got to
come to these be responsible you know
and be responsible have respect for the
substance service yeah be be very just
everybody part of you see Vegas you see
like the big parties in New York people
are party anybody so if you I'm making
all the wrong decisions especially yeah
early ages especially early ages doing a
little bit too much drugs party a little
bit too much not focused on that they
have with the proper examples right yeah
meda and that's what you said man nobody
has an example of how to be a human
being
you know sometimes we do you get you get
some people clearly yeah you get some
people out there you but I don't la that
person's like I think we all oppressed
mentors or you know I was lucky I had a
handful of great mentors that really you
know helped me stay on the path yeah I
feel very blessed for that you know yeah
I think um people that are inspiring me
like you look at Elton Brianna's athlete
good guy forever
Mary when his family and um Wow you know
and I play with these guys and we all
grew up system similar Elton you stab
holes in his shoes it was really bad
yeah yeah one day Elton had holes issues
he's averaged 20 and 10 for his career
in in there we play meet each other's
music their teens old meet him a Malden
so he had his hold and opened up in his
toe you see his whole foot coming out
as a big fifteen-year-old kid size 15
toe touching the ground you know playing
that five saw all stuck in which is the
best basketball camp on the East Coast
when we was kids the top plays go there
Michael Jordan's been there you know and
it's been and this is one cancels
competitive um you know and that's crazy
yeah I'm high it's good it's like I
think I can keep going all day I really
like everything I like I love the
podcast I love how you guys are doing
the marketing and you're here putting
out good content well produced and I
remember hearing about it and now I'm
here and the Tison trance is just like I
love doing this stuff with my wife does
stuff tennis and I'm like me she comes
down yeah yeah yeah it's really cool
relaxed environment and you're still
creative you're being very creative
which is what we are as humans anyway
yeah you know we just want to create we
do something fun and inspire and make a
little money
I wouldn't say keep smoking marijuana
and all the time but if you need it man
you know maybe you can get it prescribed
or something but it should be available
and our hair is different it's being
accepted by in Vancouver's it's super
accepted I like being out places like
that
yeah they chew smoke a little bit that's
how organ is to the organs like that
yeah yeah oh really is yeah what about
Wyoming Yellowstone - redneck from yeah
might be have you been to a while we
know people from Benton they told me
it's beautiful
right I got to go to Yellowstone Park
yeah you gotta go Yellowstone Park the
water and why oh me is a 1 I've been a
lot of places and might give me a lot of
places and the water I'm probably in my
places in happen Bahamas and in the
water and the water in Rio me is day one
really spring literally everywhere every
time you see a rep you can just jump in
and they must have walked and they got
water I got wall
shrill will bring that worries a big
predator William so you gotta be very
[ __ ] Tina Tina this is a rock star
group of production yeah we got some
[ __ ] dope ass [ __ ] dude they kick
in there that's kick-ass and he's got
positive work like he could have been
doing something else but he's like
behind the camera you probably had been
getting into trouble you know have you
ever been to Florida The Lion King [ __ ]
never happen oh this isn't video has
many stories slowly Jamin versus smart
wild animals hey this is too loud yeah I
was saying like you know they got a park
where lions and like outlines rhinoceros
oh no I never want to be I never want to
be there's a grizzly bear oh wow on this
dude I wanna die I don't like that Oh
what are you doing I wanna be still on
him
look easy I know how long he's gonna be
on oh it's gonna happen here
what are you Grisi yeah back up mega the
dude is pedaling for his life yeah they
run like 45 miles an hour
he's running yeah making hard trees why
are we going through the why - oh why
are we going through the bit with the
pair doing
this is really cool this is like what's
that show ridiculousness
yeah like like it's time for my Dyson
ridiculousness as part of the show
should be this is fun
that's a good car but look what do you
like to do with that thing I'm gonna get
oh my god I mean I'm a monster I don't
want to be in a situation that is a
monster bear dude I don't want to be
fighting though I don't even wanna
fighting a baby man you ready but you
get this be holy [ __ ] hey Mike on
YouTube everybody loves when you smoke
and you take a little hit you take the
hit from the front
hyena doesn't think as if they said why
do you do that thing I'm trying to get
every little bit that's that's how poor
people poor people smoke marijuana wow
you just want every every bit of it that
you can yeah I get it - oh [ __ ] that
dude you got tackled by that bears dead
oh these are all things they'll [ __ ] you
up when they come from no get you right
yeah with the toss would you be scared a
wild pig like that yeah look at why you
think a wild pig our teeth there's big
tusks yeah look at this I don't like
birds man beautiful yeah I mean they are
beautiful they just scare like little
dinosaurs especially like an ostrich I'd
you ever seen an ostrich ostrich yeah
oh my goodness oh please don't know what
someone's gonna have oh I hope they just
get it off oh it's a fox oh really
oh that's nice
I don't know if I'm gonna do that yeah
I'd love to leave the fires in there oh
it's very good give you a little phrase
oh that was a tough guy right there
had to show love with the show love of
God's animals oh look at this one dude
this one's nuts Oh God
what I guess ya jumps like 12 feet they
like 500 pretty this dude watch this a
500-pound watch this when you come to
Thea my theme already theme coming well
you know why looky this alright look at
that beautiful amazing look at that
thing oh that's nuts
what's your name is Joe please hotbox
I'm hotboxing
with Mike Tyson you got our YouTube
channel so how many times have your
episodes we get a lot quite a few go
this is where that bear came from over
500,000 subscribers that's where stoked
to have you have you had any exotic
animals from no I've heard of Tyson's
animals obviously on YouTube and where
you get to see most of the videos a lot
of things on VHS and I've seen all the
animals and I've seen you wrestle with
the big one which I'm like no no way I
can do that yeah they have very little
pups oh wow coming kid well we could go
all day
what else is going on Mehta yeah
with Matt have any projects any
businesses yeah a lot of things mints I
got this I got a verse export yeah Mets
verse exports we're just trying to bring
basketball games to more places in
Europe yep we want to try to get our
kids the Europe we want to try to get
our kids to China and want to try to get
them to the NBA you know and we want to
have fun I like coaching you know so
when I was retired what am I gonna do
you know and I'm just like you know
trying to get into something I love and
basketball something that I love so I'm
like you can still monetize off
basketball put out basketball games
where companies like Facebook you know
you know all you can coach and then one
day I want to be a head coach also so if
I had an opportunity to be a head coach
right now honestly I probably would've
been head coach somewhere if I had the
opportunity but I love basketball you
know and um we're gonna be doing leagues
and then hopefully if that's successful
then we get to tennis I really like
tennis pretty awesome - I'm a tenth
parent thank you that's great
both you guys are I know yes I know
those daughter plays and my daughter is
back playing tennis you know and I think
tennis should be available more I feel
like she can't play a lot of games you
know she can't play enough games where
um you know she could play we don't have
to be with the USTA sometimes is USTA
people are not at their level that's a
hard level my daughter got smashed sound
like anything fire keep playing and she
quit the one day she lost really bad and
she quit and I'm like you know I don't
want to play but she's 15 now she wants
to play again so I'm like okay well back
at that's awesome yeah yeah cool I like
playing tennis
I like fan yeah I'm in life after
football you play I do
oh yeah but Janis one day let's do a
bring you bring the cameras out gonna be
a to be like playing pro you play man
free content
yeah the cameras are something to just
get the blood feels good you know it's
fun
no way no way no way Wow
put Mike Tyson playing tennis you see my
baby there you go oh there you go oh
nice yeah oh wow that's really cool hey
bro you shake that bad does she really
want to like take go to pro yeah yeah
and every time I talk to Mike about say
she's really good she's still feeling to
mom and she loves it she's gonna amazing
at it I was really cool the tennis is
cool man who's your favorite athlete in
tennis who's your favorite man have to
be serene that arena the real animal
yeah she's awesome yeah I've seen her
play and Stanford yeah I took my
daughter and we watched her play and she
was like what you doing here I'm like
you Plains it that's it yeah yeah and
took a picture with my daughter
Venus dude yeah I'm all 302 for my
daughter so happy it was cool we got the
picture man I was really excited me yes
I was good yeah that's awesome dude well
we got a little gift for you man I come
we got the official Tyson ranch better
cannabis supersoft it's a double XL
I love the Tyson range I'm gonna I'm
gonna lift home you know my response I
love how things is nowadays I can yep
you know and chill and you can chill and
be modest and I got a Tyson ranch thank
you
you know I need a ranch in New York
prairies to getting the cameras young
kids they're picking everything I would
get the time to take me through and
gentle at the cabin I pay though
badass kick get man [ __ ] dude well get
somewhere hell yeah brother
that looks like it'll be perfect when
you when they first when they first said
like when he first said um it's how much
I know to expect yeah I know and
everybody's trying to get into the mid
marijuana business everybody's out here
and she has like viola yeah and
everybody's doing something different
like a while and to actually see it like
as an actual business is really cool
it's also just like it's inspiring and
I'll put this on but I definitely
support its good brother I love the hood
hi good look good looks good man awesome
I cannot play to be a mentor for some
way out with you man can I please put in
my life and marry this old Italian guy
taught me how to box man in my life I
think what kind of white guy teach me
about fighting lose do not know right
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] how did he pick
me how did this happen yeah yeah
and so before that if you are not
fighting never please pull that a lot of
street fighters don't fight rob somebody
ha ha deep in the neighborhood Wow I
heard all the stories and you know we
talked to I never like camera which is
like really cool because every time you
was going through your stuff you're all
the fans all my heart I hope my doing
okay always always and people like that
with me too because I was going through
some stuff too on the only going off so
it's like to see somebody idolize and
I'm actually going to a little bit my
own stuff you know you have life and
life turned yeah yeah and as well it is
a really cool being here you know big
fans I never got a chance to say this on
just like them passing I've seen Mike
had a red carpet that's the first time I
saw much it might says hey brother Ron
and I literally this guy knows by name
yo when you said call my dad
I'm not your dad Tyson said brother
wrong
well no my dad was a fighter and I got
your story so the Angelo Angelo Dundee
before he was um before he passed away
at my I wanted to fight with my dad for
it so I said dad about training bout by
the time I'm 24 by the time I'm 35 I'll
feel good Friday because I know it took
you like 10 years beautiful youth
champion you know tell you in from 14 14
13 in the 13 14 and I became champion at
20
oh wow wow so six years yeah wow so I'm
like I knew and I love boxers are that
there's no way that I would ever fight I
don't have at least 10 years of training
or training and as I turn I'll turn pro
by that time I'm 35 so he's gonna
announce it Angelo Dundee was helping me
and he passed away I had to bro and they
went the bro happen I said there's no
way I'm gonna announce that I'm fighting
now because it was too much was coming
down on me at that time so I said dad
like this is not smart like we should
not be trying to fight and didn't mr.
Dundee passed away me that yeah business
wasn't meant for us to be there be
fighting but I'm such a huge fan I
support fighters I go to to get to
fights you know I pay my tickets because
I enjoy it I enjoy people seeing I'm hit
and people losing their lives over this
game so something I earn generous
support and you know listen I've been a
little kid my mentor got me fill into
this stuff of fight I envy those I
wanted to be those fighters like I leave
a burger and I wanted to be them so bad
I thought I could beat them better than
they could be themselves
Wow yeah I wanted to be channel one to
grow up so fast I could be champ both of
the kids I want to grow up yesterday I
thought that was so cool - yeah makes a
lot of sense I mean and people do
realize how smart Mike wasn't like with
the history of boxing the history of
boxes like going to school like that
should be a course you know what I'm
saying it should be a course because
it's very complicated and then the
physical part obviously right the
business part then how did you you dug
back into Rocky Marciano even deeper cuz
you which is really good and then when
you start it inspired me to it inspiring
me to go back and look at these fighters
you were talking about which is hard it
was hard the Final Four
you know funny because because somebody
offered me a road reason me to play this
ex-slave that one is freedom Boxey
became the first black united states
champion like 1800 bro that would be
dope my what is freedom he bought his
freedom fighting after he bought his
freedom I think it manages his slave
master gave him his freedom and gave him
five dollars to fight our long under
with a lot of money and he beat
everybody in the country black white he
became a nun at the United States
Champion bare-knuckle fighter Wow do
that I was thinking about it bro then
the guy is listen this guy Tom Mullen
och he is LL Cool J great-great-great
cousin Wow
yeah Wow hello got two champions in the
family Wow boxing champions and the
other one John Henry Lewis light
heavyweight champion in 1930 Wow
for Joe Lewis okay you know I learned a
lot about Rocky Marciano because I heard
of the name and you know obviously you
was compared to hymns and I heard it a
name but I didn't know who he was I only
seen one clip yeah one clip of Joe Lewis
for years but that's me now you can
distribute content where you to but I'm
I'm like digging deep I see like oh this
is Rocky Marciano was a beast people
don't give him enough respect I think
hmm
he was he was really good I've seen him
like knock people out and he got Joe
Louis had no let him down walk Jersey
Joe
Jerry Joe add in there and Archie Moore
and then what you gotta be put down yeah
they gotta respect that
even though Mike had the best chin I
think you had the best chin I'm okay but
I think my man I'll leave the ultimate
fight who's always it was always
comparisons between you two and you know
I people had they ever no no and it was
definitely hard it wasn't us
wasn't telling Mike Rappaport our lead
is different from any other fighter
because I Lee would truly he will never
quit you have to
yeah you know he wouldn't quit he'll
fight you 2950 already around he won't
quit nice amazing he's an inspiring
person amazing individual his personal
yeah man usually uses a grand human
being yeah I like Rapoport says what's
up too by the way
yeah Michelle yeah Wow
yeah I did his show I loved the show
yeah today he wanted me to tell you a
love for him definitely he's a good good
good guy yeah he loves you guys
oh yeah that definitely I appreciate you
I have me oh yeah brother this is really
you have any friend that you hang out
what are you used to hang out with these
to play ball but didn't make it but like
when I when I played against um I played
against the Cavs on Christmas Day
everyone attacked of the finals
my man chatty got shot and on a cocaine
deal you know he beat me 32 to - when I
was 13 years old he was a dope baller
but a lot of streets you know and then
while he's on the field he came live you
didn't so like when I was coming up he
went to jail he's 15 already you know he
was in the streets he went to jail about
that so so now I'm now the best in the
hood but really mike is the best another
now I'm the best but when Mike Michaels
amazing couldn't with him yet then when
he um you know got out of jail the
opportunity to you know he's a he's a he
didn't go to college so you know junior
junior college couldn't get seen in a d1
and in the streets you know and then
died and a guy I idolized gonna came out
of jail I brought it with me to Indiana
we played basketball he was still so
nice
oh man with some honor feels like a
planning with Michael Jordan know
they're beautiful what they do some
faith but they don't want to put in that
work you know I don't Eminem could do
probably someone who could be like guys
without working out but they're so
talented
yeah gotta put in there
when you get into the deep brown and you
need that confident that you can do that
that's what they won't have yeah and
then then their crumble
yeah how good they are how talented they
are they have to have the determination
and that will to win yeah I doubt that
you're nothing and discipline they lack
the discipline that's why they weren't
successful yep yeah okay how good you
are without discipline you nothing yeah
I believe so yeah what's down jab well
you want to give any shoutouts before we
get out of here definitely so thanks for
having me on Tyson rands Metta World
Peace check out X verse exports calm I'm
trying to get basketball to exciting
basketball more two different cities in
America you know starting in Los Angeles
and taking our new level rise and give
people opportunities you know to make it
to their dreams NBA and stuff I had
those opportunities I had people help me
you know so it's coaching is still
coaching and you can do it on a platform
so that's what I'm doing now and um just
having a great time and I'm still
playing basketball you know I coach with
the G League Lakers last year which is
fun you know so yeah man it's great to
have you man absolutely I'll come back
anytime brother and definitely its
mobile yes yeah we need to do all right
so Mike Mike yeah I'm hotboxing had met
men apiece murder world men and world
peace oh yeah all the world he happy
I've been Britain I'm Mike Tyson I'm out
we're out baby
[Music]